[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer la soirée dans les Yvelines
avec au menu de l'actualité des
Infopratique et des idées de sortie
voici le sommaire de ce lundi 13 mars il
jette l'éponge Mustapha lahbaoui a
décidé de démissionner du conseil
municipal de Trappes numéro 3 sur les
listes d'Othman nasrow lors de la
dernière élection partielle il avait
déjà pris ses distances du groupe
d'opposition menées par l'élu de droite
Mustapha lahbaoui et notre invité tout
au long de la semaine TV 78 vous fait
vivre une journée avec Fabien Lambert
recruté par la mairie de Beynes il est
depuis octobre dernier le premier éco
garde professionnel des Yvelines ces
missions veillez aux espaces verts et
naturels de la commune immersion et puis
le club de plaisir Les Clayes-sous-Bois
se relancent après deux défaites en
National 3 de handball les Yvelines
noires se sont imposés 30 24
Avranches samedi soir le résumé de la
rencontre dans notre partie sport et ce
sera avec notre journaliste sport de la
rédaction TV 78 Michael est le numéro
bonsoir bonsoir et vous allez aussi nous
livrer les l'ensemble des résultats
sportifs du week-end on parle de quoi ce
soir on va parler box ça va être Tony
Yoka qui a perdu je pense que vous
l'avez tous vu devant votre télévision
contre eux Carlos Takam nous parlons
aussi de Poissy qui a fait match nul ce
weekend dans le championnat de National
2 et on parlera de tous les résultats
sportifs et on aura aussi des Amazones
deux invités deux Amazones qui viendront
ici pour parler du raid Amazon qui
partira ce dimanche au Sri Lanka mais il
sera tout à l'heure dans la partie sport
juste en face de vous réginerales de la
rédaction de TV 78 bonsoir Régine vous
allez nous parler dans un instant de ce
qu'il faut retenir de l'actualité de ce
lundi 13 mars dans les Yvelines avec les
informations du jour à vos côtés
Mustapha Larbaoui bonsoir bonsoir à vous
bonsoir hôtel merci d'être avec nous et
je le disais tout récent démissionnaire
du conseil municipal de Trappes vous
nous direz dans un instant les raisons
de cette
ça fait ça fait chaud au cœur de cette
célébration parce que ça fait oui ça
fait 40 ans effectivement que je suis
rentré à la mairie le 6 mars 83
on part toujours on part pour un mandat
bon 2 et puis je suis au septième quoi
vous voyez donc ça fait ça fait plaisir
ça fait vraiment que quand j'ai appris
que j'allais avoir une place à mon
nombre ça fait ça m'a surpris ça fait
plaisir et j'étais je suis heureux de
d'en arriver là quoi mais je continuais
avec plaisir c'est 40 ans de début de
possible et on va revenir sur cette
histoire dans un instant vous parliez de
cette place qui a été inauguré à votre
nom c'est l'un des hommages rendus par
la ville de Poissy pour ces 40 ans de
mandats dans cette émission nous
parlerons aussi de la prochaine édition
de tequinov qui arrive bientôt en sera
le 28 mars du côté de Paris on en
parlera avec deux invités Laurent
Legendre qui est président de t'équinov
et Patrick rakotosu la saison de la
Chambre de commerce et d'industrie non
pas des Yvelines mais de l'Essonne qui
co-organisent cet événement voilà vous
connaissez le programme et juste avant
de le dérouler on va jeter un coup
d'oeil aux prévisions météo de demain
le vent qui va souffler assez fort
demain matin dans les Yvelines avec des
rafales à 50 km/h annoncé quelques
éclaircies prévus le matin sur
l'ensemble du territoire côté
température il fera 8 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Versailles 7 degrés à
Houdan et Versailles l'après-midi de la
pluie pourrait tomber sur le département
côté température 9 degrés sur le secteur
Nord et Centre du département 8 degrés à
Rambouillet et ce mardi à 14 mars nous
fêterons les Mathilde on fait le pont
tout de suite sur les informations du
jour dans les Yvelines
informations de ce lundi à 13 mars avec
vous bien sûr Régine Rallet si on
commence avec une information transport
tout à fait Grégory après plusieurs
annulations de train et de retard dans
les transports entre les mois de
septembre et de décembre 2022 les
détenteurs du passe Navigo vont pouvoir
être indemnisés demain mardi 4 4 mars
Île-de-France mobilité ouvrira sa
plateforme de remboursement pour les des
transports en commun les indemnités
seront comprises entre 37,60 € et 75
euros 20 la plateforme de remboursement
est ouverte pour une durée d'un mois
quelque chose Michael oui effectivement
j'ai pu aller au net récemment et j'ai
vu oui effectivement lui sq7 qui est
partira depuis je crois aux États-Unis
mais là il y a un nouveau nano satellite
qui va être lancé tout prochainement qui
a été développé justement par
l'Observatoire de Versailles à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le CNRS et
Sorbonne université et son nom alors
c'est pas usq7 c'est inspire 7 qui va
bientôt rejoindre les étoiles c'est
comme ça exactement il se nano satellite
il est dédié justement à l'observation
de la Terre et du soleil il sera lancé
le 3 avril prochain depuis sa base
américaine de Vandenberg en Californie
et le but entre autres c'est de mesurer
le bilan radiatif et non pas radioactif
de la terre d'embarquer de nouveaux
équipements technologiques et de former
les étudiants dans un métier de
l'ingénierie spatiale
7 7 j'ai pas buté sur le nom au
contraire du vsq-7 voilà j'ai réussi à
le prononcer dans son cette émission
continue avec le chiffre du jour Régine
218 750 pourquoi
dimanche 12 mars la maison de vente aux
enchères au Sénat situé à Versailles à
CD un document unique c'est une lettre
de Robespierre qui a été adressée à
Danton elle a été écrite le 15 février
1793 et dans cette lettre Robespierre y
exprime son soutien envers son ami
Danton qui venait de perdre son épouse
décédé le 10 février et la lettre a été
adjugée au prix de 218 750 euros et elle
appartient désormais un collectionneur
parisien samedi 11 mars la clé des
champs de la ville de Plaisir organisé
une soirée 100% électro et il y avait
des grands noms de la scène
internationale on pouvait d'ailleurs
citer elisa do Brasil qui est aussi
surnommée la reine de la drum and bass
en France il y avait également Arnaud
Rebotini qui est venu faire découvrir
les morceaux de son dernier Eprave East
ou encore des artistes régionaux tels
que le groupe double Biox deep et flayou
les fans d'electro étaient assez ravis
on écoute tout de suite les réactions
micro de Mathilde de francfou ah j'adore
je suis sûr qu'il de elisa do Brasil
vraiment c'est ça permet de se libérer
encore
et on termine les informations du jour
avec une activité insolite samedi 11
mars l'association Mani badminton a
organisé un tournoi de blackmington
c'est une activité dont le but est de
jouer au badminton dans le noir seul les
lignes volant effilées étaient
fluorescents pour permettre aux joueurs
de voir le jeu
merci à l'association Mani badminton de
nous les avoir fournis Merci à VOUS
Régina rage pour ces informations du
jour et comme d'habitude si vous aussi
près de chez vous vous êtes témoin d'un
fait d'une information et qui vous fait
réagir n'hésitez pas à le dire en
utilisant sur les réseaux sociaux le
hashtag 78 news Mustapha Larbaoui je le
disais vous êtes donc conseillé
municipal démissionnaire désormais de
Trappes un ville dont tes mères Ali
rabais vous avez pris la décision
démissionner de cette fonction vous
l'annoncer ce soir officiellement sur TV
78 en octobre déjà et même il y a
quelques mois vous annoncier vous mettre
en retrait du groupe d'opposition menée
par Hotmail avec qui vous aviez fait
campagne en 2020 lors de l'élection
municipale à Trappes et aussi en 2021
lors de l'élection municipale partielle
puisqu'on rappelle que le résultat de
l'élection 2020 avait été invalidé pour
quelle raison démissionnez-vous du
conseil municipal alors l'information
c'est qu'effectivement j'ai remis ma
lettre de démission à Monsieur le Maire
je lance un appel s'il y a des enchères
pour une lettre qui peut être
intéressante peut-être qu'elle pourrait
monter jusqu'à 200000 € comme celle de
Robespierre et Danton c'était vendredi
la démission donc vendredi par les trop
commandé voilà donc j'ai remis ma lettre
de démission mais pour être dans la
sincérité parce que je crois qu'il faut
toujours l'être surtout avec des gens
qui ont voté pour nous ma sortie déjà du
groupe de la majorité de l'époque était
un signe pour moi que je prenais déjà du
recul du recul par rapport à cette
activité que je qualifie de politique
même si pour moi ça reste de la
politique le calme j'étais parti sur un
projet j'étais parti sur un engagement
d'union locale c'était donc un
engagement et puis les choses ont fait
que c'était devenu un engrenage puisque
covid oblige recours sur recours
tribunaux etc c'est devenu un engrenal
dans lequel je suis resté alors qu'en
réalité probablement je serai sorti déjà
depuis
allez on va dire avril ou mai 2020 après
les élections parce que mon engagement
il était total et sincère pour aller
dans l'action et je me voyais pas dans
le position pour m'opposer ou pour avoir
une attitude ou un réflexe d'opposition
j'entends et voilà donc le fait que je
sois resté dans un engrenage fait que
j'ai attendu un moment que les choses se
tassent et aujourd'hui je trouve que
c'est le bon moment c'est le bon moment
parce que
je n'ai jamais mélangé en fait pour tout
vous dire tout le monde sait tous ceux
qui me connaissent c'est ici souvent
Lady mon engagement il est associatif
depuis une quarantaine d'années
ce qui me permet de de m'adresser à
monsieur qui a un engagement de 40
années en politique moi c'est un
engagement associatif depuis 40 ans et
déçu de la politique du coup alors je
dirais pas déçu parce qu'une déception
c'est qu'on s'y attend quelque chose de
particulier et on en est déçu je savais
où je m'étais les pieds je savais que je
rentrais dans un monde que je ne
connaissais pas et donc par le pour du
coup j'allais apprendre des choses
évidemment et j'aurais des difficultés
mais j'aimerais également des bonheur
parce que c'est quand même un moment
important mais c'est surtout que je ne
veux pas mélanger c'est-à-dire que quand
j'ai fait de la politique que je me suis
lancé en 2019 j'ai abandonné tous mes
mandats de président de club de foot de
pharmacie président du club formation
également avec des établissements j'ai
jamais voulu mélanger attirer des gens
dans la société pour les emmener avec
moi dans le politique on n'est pas un
tel rôle dans l'opposition est-ce que
peut-être vous êtes aussi je dirais le
terme mauvais perdant de du résultat de
l'élection 2021 vous attendiez peut-être
à plus à être dans la majorité justement
perdant claire mauvais perdant pas du
tout d'abord j'étais pas tête de liste
s'il y avait quelqu'un qui devait se
revendiquer de gagner ou de perdre c'est
la tête de liste et nous avec lui donc
perdu et c'est la raison pour laquelle
je ma façon de faire de la politique
c'est souvent c'est presque à la Jospin
quoi dire que je m'engage mais c'est
pour gagner je m'engage c'est pour
l'action je m'engage c'est pour faire
des choses je m'engage et et là je me
suis retrouvé dans l'opposition et très
sincèrement je je j'ai pas ma place j'ai
pas l'impression que ça à grand chose
je me demande à quoi sert l'opposition
elle est justement l'engrenage que vous
décrivez vous pensez que c'est un cas
général aux oppositions ou c'est
peut-être un cas particulier sur cette
ville de Trappes où on sait que les
tensions ont été quand même au
rendez-vous notamment durant les
campagnes municipales oui des tensions
il y en a eu dans cette ville il y en a
eu dans d'autres mais l'engrenage à
laquelle je faisais référence c'était
pas un engrenage au sens opposition
majorité l'engrenage c'est que je suis
rentré pensant sortir tôt et que les
choses freiné par les différents procès
qu'on a eu et qui a eu pardon mais non
je pense que c'est ça je suis plutôt
fait pour l'associatif et aujourd'hui je
reprends l'association pharmaceutoyante
et je retrouve les bénévoles dans le
monde associatif j'ai encore fait
récemment de très belles rencontres au
travers des clubs de foot les bénévoles
c'est vraiment des gens à qui j'attache
beaucoup beaucoup d'importance et donc
voilà c'est une manière de dire je
mélange j'ai jamais mélangé je ne
mélange pas je retourne à la société
est-ce que vous regrettez aujourd'hui ce
combat que vous avez mené dans dans le
monde politique est-ce que si cette
affaire vous le referiez peut-être seul
et pas en alliance avec Otman Nasco
alors ça c'est des choses qui ont été
dites mille fois tu aurais dû y aller en
tête de liste c'est très flatteur mais
je suis pas là pour être flatté je suis
là pour faire de la politique et j'ai
toujours dit si je gagne je serai pas en
capacité peut-être parce que j'ai pas de
mouvement politique j'ai pas de groupe
politique derrière moi donc j'ai préféré
m'adosser un mouvement politique
mais je regrette absolument pas à la
fois ce qu'on a fait ensemble avec
Othman et toute l'équipe je regrette
absolument pas ce qu'on a vécu malgré
les tensions dont vous parlez je
regrette absolument rien la seule chose
que je regrette c'est pas avoir gagné
parce que je suis un homme d'action et
j'avais quand même un projet en tête et
si j'ai un si j'ai un appel à faire pour
le coup au monde politique c'est et la
part de moi si je vais s'il y a des
choses qui sont
mal prises mais je pense qu'on devrait
faire beaucoup beaucoup plus et là je
m'adresse à tous les adultes les adultes
en général et les politiques en
particulier pour l'enfant c'est à dire
être moins tourné vers des projets qui
sont importants tout est important les
seniors l'habitat enfin tous les mais le
dossier de l'éducation est ultra
ultra prioritaire chez moi et tout
tourne autour de ça c'est pour ça que je
repars association internationale
associatif pharmaceutoriel on sait que
vous êtes aussi très attaché à la ville
de Trappes est-ce que du coup la page
politique est totalement fermée où elle
pourrait se rouvrir pourquoi pas
la prochaine élection municipale en 2026
au sein peut-être d'un engagement
associatif avec votre association
pharmaceutoyen on entre nous là c'est
pas enregistré non non direct on est
problème c'est que ça m'est arrivé de
dire jamais jamais et de faire quand
même certaines choses comme la pharmacie
de Sicile je vous l'ai dit jamais donc
j'ai pas envie de le dire mais oui
sincèrement c'est une parenthèse que
j'ai ouverte qui était parti pour trois
mois elle se referme au bout de deux ans
elle se referme merci à Mustapha
lahbaoui et d'être venu là nous en
plateau juste un mot très rapide juste
pour remercier tous ceux qu'on voté pour
nous et je veux céder ma place à
quelqu'un qui va travailler et qui va
faire partie du conseil municipal de la
liste qui va monter prendre ma place et
faire le job donc un engagement
politique qui a été au final assez court
et en face de vous il y a 40 années de
service politique au sein d'un conseil
municipal je disais tout à l'heure un
Georges Monnier vous avez fêter
récemment quarante années comme conseil
municipal de la ville de Poissy un
anniversaire qui a été célébré le 6 mars
dernier 6 mars 1983 c'est la date à
retenir vous faisiez votre entrée comme
conseiller municipal
UDF à l'époque et alors anecdote aussi à
souligner c'est le même jour où Gérard
Larcher devenu maire de Rambouillet le 6
mars 1983 le président du Sénat vous
avez d'ailleurs fait l'honneur d'être
présent le jour de la cérémonie un lundi
dernier ça vous a fait quoi qu'il soit
présent pour vous shower bon je connais
Gérard depuis 40 ans bon ça c'est la
même partie politique et puis ça fait 40
ans que je rencontre
pas régulièrement faire un compte
souvent Gérard
et puis j'ai rencontré dernièrement
l'histoire ce que je vais rencontrer la
dernière fois c'était lors de la
libération de Poissy celle-là la
célébration
et Gérard était là il m'a dit Georges
Benoît qui me fait T40
mais tu sais que moi aussi j'ai été élu
le 6 mars au fêtera ça bon voilà donc on
va fêter donc après ça s'est organisé et
il me dit je vais venir j'ai eu vendredi
dernier j'ai eu son chef de cabini qui
m'a dit
le président veut venir
bon c'est un peu tendu quand même le
Sénat actuellement avec les retraites
le président va venir il va se
débrouiller mais il viendra
j'ai j'avais un peu peur et puis je l'ai
vu arriver assez rapide ça fait chaud au
coeur
je connais depuis longtemps vous portez
justement Mustapha oui vous qui a eu qui
avait eu un engagement assez court
finalement en politique peut-être qui se
rouvrira plus tard on ne sait pas mais
sur quelqu'un qui a 40 années derrière
lui de conseils municipal on a un point
commun c'est des quarantaine et
associatif et dans le monde politique
pour le coup moi ça a été plus bref moi
j'aurais une question si je me permets
c'est la question que je poserai à
Monsieur franchement dans les
municipales l'opposition ça sert à rien
mais je suis pas d'accord bah oui mais
justement juste pour préciser vous avez
été vous aussi dans l'opposition vous
avez connu quatre mères au cours de vos
sept mandats vous le disiez comme
conseiller municipal il y a eu chaque
masse de la rue le maire pour lequel
vous avez débuté vous avez vous êtes
entré au conseil municipal le 6 mars
1988 vous avez fait quatre mandats avec
lui il y a eu aussi un mandat dans
l'opposition avec Frédéric Bernard mère
socialiste de Poissy et aussi des
mandats car l'olive et maintenant avec
la nouvelle mère de Poissy tout récente
Sandrine Bernot Dos Santos bah justement
vous avez connu cette fonction de
conseil municipal d'opposition je vous
laisse répondre là dessus
quand vous êtes le battus après 80
mandats c'est dur c'est dur parce que
bon mais
on a été quelques-unes d'être élu dans
l'opposition et on s'est dit
on peut pas rester là il faut continuer
il faut aller honnêtement il faut il
faut y aller il faut être partout il
faut il faut essayer de les contrôler
bon l'idée est toujours c'est de dire
c'est pas fini d'incident
d'un six ans on peut revenir
26 ans on peut y aller mais je peux vous
dire que pendant six ans
gentiment et bon mais
dit qu'ils oubliés un peu on leur a
rappelé au conseil municipal vraiment on
a étudié tous les tous les dossiers
voilà pendant 6 ans ça a été dur donc on
peut exister quand même dans
l'opposition
on peut proposer on peut être force de
proposition on peut on peut se cogner ce
que je veux dire c'est que ça écrase
tellement parce que probablement que les
gens ne savent pas tout à fait comment
ça fonctionne mais on a 60 vide 75% des
élus ça écrase tout en clair si on est
en face de nous quelqu'un de conciliant
et qui laisse un peu de place on peut
prendre un peu de place ou alors faut se
battre mais normalement on devrait pas
se battre on est démocrates je suis
arrivé à faire changer Bernard
vous avez 78 ans vous êtes un ancien
cadre des PTT qu'est-ce qui vous a
poussé en 1983 vous lancer justement
dans la politique locale à cet
engagement pour la ville voici qu'est-ce
qui vous a poussé à l'époque
j'ai rencontré un 72
un docteur Poissy on est arrivé à 60 je
suis arrivé à 71 ça va à Poissy et 72 on
a rencontré quelqu'un un docteur faire
médecin à coucher pour être tranquille
voilà
chercher un médecin à cause accoucher
et je suis tombé sur le docteur block
et voilà donc c'est rencontré plusieurs
fois on a discuté puis c'est avéré qu'on
avait les mêmes les mêmes idées quoi
et puis à la mairie il y avait fait il y
avait une municipalité
communiste socialiste
c'était pas tout à fait notre vue donc
voilà j'ai commencé un truc à faire un
peu de tout petit que j'ai pris aussi ma
carte au Parti républicain parce que
j'étais membre du parti républicain et
en 86
il faut qu'on monte il faut qu'on monte
une lisse il faut que il y avait à
l'époque si vous voulez il y avait il y
avait les deux groupes il y avait le
groupe RPR un groupe RPR et un groupe
EDF grosse discussion entre les deux
auquel je participais etc et puis c'est
entendu pour monter une liste un tiers
RPR un tiers EDF un tiers de non
inscrits
au final vous êtes rentrés au conseil
municipal et vous l'avez dit quatre
mandats avec Jacques messe de rue Arus
un mandat dans l'opposition un mandat et
car le livre un mandat avec Sandrine
Bernaud Dos Santos qui est en cours et
vous avez jamais songé être même ça vous
a jamais traversé l'esprit
vous savez quand vous êtes élu que vous
avez un maire qui est super sympa qui
qui bosse bien avec avec
des coups de France je veux dire j'ai
pris j'ai pris la voirie j'ai pris
j'ai pris les bâtiments bon avait
monsieur ça allait bien bon pourquoi
pourquoi changer il était il était maire
il a été député quoi c'est général non
non non ça vous a jamais traversé
l'esprit alors en tout cas vous avez été
aussi à côté de ça pendant 25 ans vous
avez présidé le centre social Beauregard
qui s'appelle aujourd'hui André Malraux
quand vous regardez vos 40 années
qu'est-ce qui vous rend le plus fier
aujourd'hui ce qui est un dossier que
vous avez aimé porter un peu plus qu'un
autre est-ce que quelque chose qui
ressort quel est votre meilleur souvenir
le centre social de Beauregard c'est un
dossier
pendant 25 ans j'étais président du
Centre quand je suis arrivé en 86 il y
avait c'était géré par une association
qui n'est pas du maire donc bon ça a été
compliqué j'ai eu quelques périodes
difficiles parce que quand vous arrivez
dans un endroit si vous voulez c'était
géré par
le président de l'association c'était
mère adjoint communiste et moi je suis
arrivé là un peu c'est pas c'est pas
évident je me rappellerai toujours
trois semaines après
l'association avait décidé d'organiser
le fait pour fêter un peu la réélection
du maire du maire avant je me suis
retrouvé j'ai pas pu annuler cette fête
et je me suis retrouvé devant 200
personnes
qui avaient la majorité voté pour
l'ancien maire je vous garantis que si
je me souviens toujours de discours que
j'ai été obligé de faire c'est ça a été
dur bon après et après pendant 25 ans
bon petit le petit est arrivé à
reprendre et on a fait si vous voulez le
centre d'après c'est développé et un
truc que j'ai
que j'ai tenu et sur lequel je crois que
je suis arrivé 86 il n'y avait aucune
fille dans le centre
il y avait les gamines de 6 ans c'est un
il n'y avait aucune jeune fille dans le
centre aucune
elles étaient interdites
au bout de quelques années je suis
arrivé à les faire venir mais ça a été
dur j'ai entendu on le disait tout à
l'heure pour célébrer vos 40 années il y
a une place qui va porter votre nom
alors la plaque a déjà été inaugurée
sera au sein du futur quartier Maurice
Claira à Poissy laissez votre trace
durablement comme ça aussi à Poissy ça
j'imagine c'est une fierté je vous le
disais tout à l'heure
on a une réunion de liste tous les
lundis et puis c'est là où
avait vu
on regardait si vous voulez les
délibérations du prochain du conseil
municipal qui est derrière et on arrive
à la septième
on a dénommé un certain nombre de rues
mais il reste une plaque la plaque à
mettre sur une place
je vous propose un peu Georges Monique
[Musique]
vous en reveniez pas
et dernière question est-ce que c'est
votre dernier mandat ou qu'on vous
comptez continuer bon écoutez je vais
pas vous dire
ça m'embête je vais vous répondre parce
que personne ne regarde pas
enregistré
deux ou trois mandats que j'avais dit à
cadre je commence à quand même un bon
j'ai besoin de toi tu connais la ville
tu connais le fonctionnement de la
mairie il faut que tu viennes
j'y suis allé en 2020
bon c'est le dernier en tout cas mais 40
années quand même derrière vous de mon
domicile
c'est peut-être le temps effectivement
de s'arrêter mais en tout cas bon
anniversaire Georges Monnier même si
c'était il y a une semaine pour ces 40
ans de mandats comme conseil municipal
de Poissy merci d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle deuxième adjoint de Poissy
délégué aux espaces publics à la
propreté urbaine et à la commande
publique on va faire la rencontre à
présent après avoir fait votre rencontre
Georges Monnier de Fabien Lambert il est
le premier ecogare de professionnel des
Yvelines recrutés en octobre 2022 par la
mairie de Beynes pour veiller aux
espaces verts de la commune Mathilde
Franco l'a suivi lors de ses différentes
missions le temps d'une journée
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Fabien je suis éco
garde pour la commune de Beynes dans les
Yvelines je suis le premier écho garde
salarié du département
et donc aujourd'hui vous allez me suivre
durant une journée durant l'émission
donc allez c'est parti
[Musique]
je peux pas fouiller à pied avec ma
voiture pour me rendre plus proche des
sites à surveiller ou aussi en quad
électrique pour circuler sur les chemins
plus facilement
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on a un animal qui a été
retrouvé mort cette nuit sur le bord de
la route on va devoir s'y rendre pour
demander l'évacuation
[Musique]
donc aujourd'hui on se retrouve face à
un animal qui a été blessé durant la
nuit il est aujourd'hui sur le bas-côté
de la route donc on m'a appelé on l'a
signalé je me suis rendu sur site pour
identifier la taille de l'animal le type
d'animal ensuite grâce à une application
sur smartphone je vais pouvoir
l'identifier et le répertorier donc ici
on est sur un chevreuil enfin une petite
forêt de plus précisément ça arrive
qu'il y ait certaines fois où on en
retrouve plusieurs d'affilée certaines
fois où c'est assez calme j'ai eu de
tout des sangliers des chevreuils des
blaireaux des chats ça arrive aussi
[Musique]
moi aussi signalé la présence d'un dépôt
sauvage dans un champ à proximité de la
commune on va aujourd'hui s'y rendre
pour essayer de retrouver des preuves et
le propriétaire du dépôt on y va
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également c'est le
rendez-vous des acteurs de l'innovation
la convention d'affaires équinov revient
le 28 mars au Parc Floral de Paris à 50
ans en Yvelines sera présente au travers
de ces entreprises le territoire Albina
aussi d'autres territoires et
d'innovation l'objectif c'est de
favoriser les rencontres entre grands
groupes PME structures de recherche
startup et investisseurs pour faire du
business et pour en parler deux invités
m'ont rejoint en plateau Laurent
Legendre bonsoir bonsoir président de
tékinov est également délégué régional à
Airbus développement et en face de vous
Patrick rakotosson bonsoir président de
la Chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
l'Essonne territoire bien sûr
limitrophes des Yvelines puisque la CCI
Sun co-organise cet événement tequinox
qui va s'ouvrir et qui neuve très
prochainement dans un contexte
particulier l'an passé vous faisiez
votre premier salon en présentiel après
la période covid 19 une nouvelle crise
aussi qui s'est ouverte avec le début de
cette guerre en Ukraine de nouveaux
enjeux qui sont apparus la cybersécurité
la défense la énergétique et ce week-end
on a appris également Laurent Legendre
la faille de la banque américaine de la
tech de la Silicon Valley banque Bruno
Le Maire le ministre de l'Économie
exclut toute contagion en France est-ce
que du coup vous allez aborder ce salon
dans un dans un état d'esprit un petit
peu d'inquiétude un esprit un peu
particulier comment vous allez l'aborder
technique n'a pas attendu qu'il y ait
une catastrophe dans une banque de
financement de start-up puisque c'est le
cas pour se préoccuper du financement
des startups bien sûr depuis 17 ans
c'est une des thématiques importantes
sur ce salon que d'aider les startups à
rencontrer des investisseurs les
préparer au pitch et surtout les
accompagner dans leur stratégie de
financement et cette année nous
renforçons la présence des banques
puisque nous avons la première banque de
financement des startups en France la
BPI qui vient pour la première fois sur
le salon l'état d'esprit Patrick
rakotosson il est au beau fixe aussi
pour vous il est au beau fixe alors je
voudrais rappeler déjà que c'est la CCI
Essonne qui
mais qui a donné une dimension
suffisamment importante à cet événement
pour que aujourd'hui elle est un
rayonnement régional et même national et
c'est pour ça que nous l'organisons au
parc floral sur 5000 m², cet événement
qu'il est né il y a 17 ans à Évry en
Essonne qui ensuite s'est exporté à Orly
pour remonter jusqu'à la défense et
enfin atterrir au Parc Floral donc c'est
quand même très important oui nous avons
énormément de succès à ce niveau là
puisque nous passons de 150 exposants
après 200 exposants nous avons l'année
dernière réussi le pari de générer 15000
conventions d'affaires rendez-vous
d'affaires avec un taux de satisfaction
de près de 98%. donc ça marche tequinox
énormément la mise en relation c'est
publicité et l'édition de cette année
Laurent Legendre en parlera plus
précisément et placer sous le signe du
plan industrie 2030 alors l'ADN on c'est
la mise en relation pourquoi faut-il
justement favoriser ces rencontres au
sein de tequinov entre start-up
investisseurs donneurs d'ordre alors
c'est très simple une start-up elle a
une idée elle va développer une techno
après il faut qu'elle arrive à la vendre
et pour la vendre il faut qu'elle arrive
à rencontrer dans l'entreprise qui est
sa future cliente qui a à peu près
identifié la bonne personne et ça c'est
le beaucoup plus compliqué
et il faut des salons pour arriver à
créer ces relations et le modèle il est
très intéressant ce sont des rendez-vous
B2B programmés avec un double
volontariat et c'est ce double
volontariat qui fait le succès des
rendez-vous
et Patrick rakotosson disait et Quino va
s'appuyer cette année sur le plan France
2030 c'est un plan d'investissement
massif hein voulu par le gouvernement 54
milliards d'euros de dotations les
objectifs affichés c'est de rattraper le
retard industriel français investir
massivement dans les technologies
innovantes ou encore de soutenir la
transition écologique c'était une belle
opportunité de s'appuyer sur sur ce plan
d'organiser tes Innov autour de France
2030 alors lorsque j'ai entendu un jour
Emmanuel Macron le 12 octobre 2021
annoncé le plan France 2030 je me suis
il faut que ce soit le thème de de tech
Inov il faut que tu tequinovienne le
salon France 2030 parce que la
réindustrialisation est un sujet majeur
et la réindustrialisation c'est
peut-être ce qu'il y a de plus compliqué
on traverse on a traversé 30 ans de
désindustrialisation inverser la
tendance c'est compliqué par contre
aller chercher l'innovation et de la
technologie dans les start-ups pour le
faire plus vite ça c'est intéressant et
d'où l'idée de
que à côté du plan de financement de 54
milliards et bien il y a ces rendez-vous
d'affaires pour que les start-ups qui
ont industrialisé un produit aille le
développer ensuite avec des grands
comptes et donc on le disait c'est un
rendez-vous qui a évolué avec le temps
qui a changé de lieu mais dans l'esprit
finalement on reste sur
le l'ADN est là la mise en relation des
conférences des présentations Flash mais
voilà surtout des rencontres on l'a bien
compris au sein de ce type de rencontre
permettre à des entrepreneurs de
l'industrie du numérique du futur de
rencontrer en un même lieu en une
journée
leur partenaire bancaire leur partenaire
fournisseurs leurs partenaires
distributeurs et pourquoi pas de trouver
de nouveaux clients et de générer aussi
le partage de technologie et en une
seule journée au travers de cet
événement et bien on arrive à générer de
façon
utile et active autant de rendez-vous
oui avec des territoires d'innovation
présent pour les Yvelines on peut parler
de l'établissement public d'aménagement
Paris-Saclay à cheval sur l'Essonne et
sur les Yvelines mais dont fait partie
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines Versailles
grands-park Rambouillet territoire c'est
sur ces territoires d'innovation qu'on
prépare demain j'ai envie de dire
Laurent Legendre oui alors les
territoires sont importants parce que
ils apportent un terreau fertile pour
développer ses et on est sur
un gros territoire qui s'appelle Paris
Saclay sur lequel on a vraiment des
localisations j'avais un sujet ce matin
sur sur Satory et le développement de
satori qui va se faire qui va
s'accélérer avec la ligne 18 on voit que
ces territoires sont en train de se
développer et se spécialisent et dans
les Territoires on peut faire naître des
filières et pour faire naître de
nouvelles filières il faut de nouveaux
acteurs et ce sont ces startups qui qui
permettent de les développer plus vite
juste aussi citer qu'il y aura un
concours justement autour des des
startups 30 start-up lauréats qui vont
être invité à technov et les gagnants
dévoilés sur plage avait une dernière
question l'an passé 1600 participants
plus de 15000 rendez-vous à l'occasion
de teknov et ce qui a un objectif
affiché pour cette année ce que vous
avez déjà une idée peut-être du nombre
de rendez-vous nombre de participants
que vous aurez cette année c'est Patrick
à date nous sommes à plus de 1800
rendez-vous participant participant plus
de 15000 rendez-vous nous avons déjà
dépassé le score de l'année dernière
nous avons même du filtré le nombre
d'exposants parce qu'on ne peut pas
pousser les murs plus que ça par contre
nous avons réussi à faire rentrer en les
murs près de 200 participants alors que
il y en avait l'année dernière ou une
et Bruno Bonnel monsieur France 2030 le
secrétaire général pour l'investissement
viendra à teknov et donc ce sera le 28
mars du côté du Parc Floral de Paris
merci à vous deux dernier mot un dernier
mot oui déjà vous remercier de nous
avoir accueilli vous avez dit qu'il y
avait trois PCI du 78 mais il y en a 10
de l'Essonne il faut pas les oublier il
faut pas les oublier et on n'oublie pas
que la CCI Sun organise l'événement
j'avais dit co-organise organise bien
sûr ce équin-off depuis le début des
services de la CCI de région
et de la CCI France merci à Patrick
racoto son président de la CCI seul
merci à Laurent Legendre président
dekinov toutes les informations sur le
site Internet de technov qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran c'est l'heure de
parler sport dans le 7 8
[Musique]
et on commence avec du handball plaisir
l'éclairs à gagner ce samedi 11 mars en
National 3 les joueurs yvelinois se sont
imposés facilement 30 à 24 contre les
derniers au classement Avranches
Grandville le résumé du match avec
Michaël el midoro et Mathilde Franco
un match pour se relancer après deux
défaites en National 3 plaisirs les clés
recevez le dernier du classement
avranches granville à l'occasion de la
15e journée du championnat pourtant ce
sont les visiteurs qui prennent
rapidement les devants dans la partie
les Illinois peine à trouver des
solutions et perdre 15 à 13 à la pause
c'était un peu compliqué au début du
match on a on a mis un peu de temps à se
mettre dedans
défensivement on a trouvé les bonnes
solutions pour les contrées mais en
concrétisait pas assez nos actions en
contre-attaque c'est une première
mi-temps qui était pas terrible vraiment
on a fait une entame de bâches où on
prend quatre ans je crois ou peut-être 5
5 1 peut-être quelque chose comme ça
donc ça a été vraiment très dur c'est
une équipe qui a plus rien à jouer dans
le championnat donc ce qui joue ultra
décomplexé ça nous a posé quelques
problèmes en seconde période plaisir les
clés plus conquérant et prend enfin
l'avantage et la 17e minute de la
seconde période avranches granville
n'arrive pas à suivre la cadence des
locaux et ne reviendra pas dans le match
score final 30 à 24 j'ai retrouvé un
système défensif plus intéressant et
offensivement on a été pour une fois
très bon en deuxième mi-temps on a
imposé le rythme aussi bien en défense
que en attaque on a passé beaucoup moins
de temps en attaque placée ce qui nous
arrange parce que c'est un peu notre
difficulté cette saison on a resserrer
les rangs en défense avec beaucoup de
récupération de balles c'est ce qui nous
a permis de refaire le retard et ensuite
de passer devant et après encore une
fois comme ils ont plus rien à jouer
dans le championnat derrière ça a été
plus facile une fois qu'on était devant
ils ont un peu lâché avec cette victoire
les Yvelinois se retrouvent à la 8e
place du championnat de National 3 leur
prochain match est programmé le samedi
25 mars à l'extérieur contre
Bois-Colombes
et Michel et le midro est revenu en
plateau pour le reste de l'actualité
sportive on continue ses résultats
Mickels avec du football dans le
championnat de National 2 Poissy n'a pu
faire mieux que match nul sur le terrain
de Saint-Pryvé-Saint-Hilaire le score un
partout classement les joueurs de Poissy
se retrouvent à la troisième place du
championnat après 21 journées à disputer
un autre rugby à présent que le
championnat de fédéral 2 Versailles cal
plaisir gagne par forfait dans ce
championnat de Fédérale 2 les Versailles
se sont inclinés à 40 à 27 sur leur
terrain contre Courbevoie l'occasion de
la 19e journée dans le même temps
plaisir gagne par forfait 25 à 0 à
domicile contre Domont au classement
plaisir est à la troisième place à deux
points de la deuxième place de son côté
Versailles et 7e et se fait doubler par
Saint-Malo de la box c'était l'événement
attendu du week-end et Tony Yoka c'est
une nouvelle fois inclinée dis-moi après
sa défaite contre Martin bacoller les
Vinois Tony Hoka perdu contre son
compatriote car le stackham ce samedi
soir au Zénith de Paris après 10 rondes
intenses les arbitres ont décidé de
prenez la victoire à son adversaire âgé
de 42 ans l'avenir du boxeur originaire
de Chanteloup-les-Vignes s'obscurcit
Tony Yoka a dit vouloir revenir plus
fort dans les prochains mois mais après
de défaite consécutives il paraît
aujourd'hui peu probable de voir les
Viennois des crochets un titre de
champion du monde dans les prochaines
années quelque chose me dit que vous
allez en parler dans si on parlait sport
l'émission sur le sport
ivinois et les athlètes Linois
exactement ce sera mercredi prochain et
on va forcément consacrer une immense
page une grosse page en tout cas sur
Tony Yoka et la suite de sa carrière
alors des déceptions peut-être aussi du
côté du basket c'est compliqué pour le
scrap 50 ans en Yvelines dans le
championnat de National 3 les Trappistes
se sont inclinés 83 à 64 sur leur
parquet contre Massy une dixième défaite
cette saison pour les joueurs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines après 20
journées disputés trap se retrouve à la
neuvième place du championnat avec une
fin de saison sans enjeu toujours du
basket mais féminin dans le championnat
de National 2 le chesnay-versa engranger
ça dixième victoire de la saison en
s'imposant sur son parquet contre bi ce
week-end avec ce résultat les Illinois
sont sixième du championnat affront
Trégueux le 18 mars un mot de cross
country avec une défaillance rarissime
j'aide le corps licencié à lea
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qu'on a
l'habitude de suivre un sur tv78 a connu
quelques déboires ce weekend lors des
championnats de France de cross country
à Carré la 50e avait quasiment gagné la
course junior dames et à 500 mètres de
l'arrivée elle a été victime d'un
malaise avant d'entamer le final vers la
ligne d'arrivée comme vous pouvez le
voir sur ces images le remportera pas
cette année son troisième titre mais
rassurez-vous la championne de 17 ans va
bien et elle espère se relever de cette
déception nous sommes bien sûr un très
bon rétablissement merci Michael on va
poursuivre cette partie sport avec deux
invités qui nous ont rejoint au plateau
on va parler du raid Amazon ce sera ce
19 mars que sera donné le grand départ
de la 23e édition de cet événement
arrête 100% féminin fondé en 2001 par
Alexandre Debanne et qui attire près de
230 sportif de toute la France et
notamment des yvelinois sur le plateau
nous avons avec nous donc Rachel Ducros
et Léa Lussac ils sont participantes
dans deux équipes différentes Rachel ce
sera pour vous l'équipe des Takara et
Léa l'équipe Red au Corrèze c'est bien
ça
alors comment vous vous sentez-vous à
faire un petit tour de micro comment
vous sentez-vous à quelques jours du
départ un patiente c'est le mot on a
vraiment envie de partir c'est mais en
même temps on a envie de savourer cette
impatience et on n'a pas envie que ça
passe trop vite donc voilà on est un peu
entre les deux en tout cas pour notre
part dans les starting block voilà
et alors ça se prépare comment dans les
dans les derniers jours alors quels sont
les derniers les dernières choses
auxquelles il faut penser dans les
derniers jours avant de partir faire le
sac maintenant
faire le sac et faire un peu une pause
sur les entraînements pour pas se
blesser on a régulièrement des petits
messages justement de Christina et
Alexandre de Banne qui nous disent stop
les filles maintenant on se repose et
venez dimanche voilà alors est-ce qu'il
y a des épreuves que vous appréhendez à
la il y aura du VTT du canoë du trail du
tir à l'arc est-ce qu'il y a des
épreuves que vous appréciez peut-être ah
oui complètement le canoë le
calme le VTT
nous disent le canoë quand même réputé
pour être l'épreuve la plus difficile
donc on verra mais a priori c'est long
c'est très
longs il y a une grosse distance en plus
cette année c'est sur un lac qu'on a pas
du tout de courant donc voilà ça va être
ça va être un vrai défi il y a pas de
petites épreuves finalement nickel non
non il y aura entre 30 et 50 km de VTT
avec du dénivelé 10 à 20 km de trail et
du canoë entre 12 et 16 km c'est quand
même pas mal oui bah là c'est c'est opté
pour 16 donc oui oui c'est beaucoup et
comment s'entraîne justement au
quotidien sur sur ces épreuves Léa
alors au quotidien on fait plutôt de la
course quand même pour être honnête
c'est ce Camus qui est plus accessible
après les session canoë on a fait
chacune de notre côté quelques-unes mais
c'est parce qu'il est plus facile
effectivement
pareil beaucoup de trails ça c'est un
sport que je pratique donc voilà je me
suis mise au VTT et le canoë on a eu la
chance d'être soutenu par le club de
Rambouillet qui nous a donné des cours
donc on va essayer de leur faire honneur
en allant à peu près droit
vous avez déjà fait des trails qu'est-ce
qui vous a poussé à vous lancer dans
cette aventure raid Amazon le côté
humanitaire est solidaire vraiment la
découverte la rencontre
le défi
le défi sportif mais en privilégiant
voilà les rencontres et
déjà rien que le fait de pas y aller
pour une médaille y aller pour un podium
c'est déjà un défi vraiment ce côté
humanitaire ouais c'est vraiment ce qui
ce qui sollicite leur est l'Amazone
pareil c'est le challenge sportif et
puis surtout les rencontres puisque
ce qu'on va vivre avec notre coéquipière
c'est quand même chouette moment puis je
rencontre qu'on va faire là-bas les
autres Amazon la population là-bas qu'on
va rencontrer c'est voilà c'est pour
l'ensemble de l'ensemble de l'événement
que c'est chouette les souvenirs qui
seront gravés à jamais dans une dans une
mémoire a priori oui
le Sri Lanka au niveau des paysages
aussi c'est ça fait rêver ah bah
carrément
on a eu beaucoup de chance alors vous
allez voir des cascades des montagnes de
thé aussi vous avez pu voir un petit peu
le parcours sur lequel vous serez on ne
connaît pas le parcours exactement
surprise oui oui mais on sait qu'on va
qu'on va avoir la chance de traverser
les plantations de thé c'est un pays où
vous connaissiez ou pas
la découverte qu'est-ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter là on a quelques jours du
grand départ du plaisir du plaisir et
des rencontres qui restent gravées à
jamais
on vous souhaite plein de réussite bonne
chance sur sur ce raid Amazon merci
d'être intervenu avec nous en plateau
bon courage pour ce raide qui est donc
on le rappelle organisé du 19 au 29 mars
au Sri Lanka vous nous envoyez quelques
photos pour qu'on suivent votre aventure
on pourra suivre
tout ça à distance un dernier mot de
sport nickel avec du sport mais cette
fois-ci pour les plus jeunes quand même
c'est tout nouveau une salle de sport et
de bien-être pour les enfants de 0 à 12
ans vient de s'ouvrir rue Témara à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye un concept créé en
2016 avec un premier centre à Orgeval au
programme des cours de Baby Gym du yoga
pour les enfants encore de la danse on
écoute la fondatrice de ce centre une
certaine Isabelle Matuidi elle était
présente ce samedi 11 mars lors de
l'inauguration il y avait peu
d'activités proposées pour nos enfants
pour nos petits bouts pour les éveiller
de manière en toute sécurité et dans un
cadre agréable et également d'un petit
constat personnel parce que étant déjà
maman de à l'époque j'étais déjà maman
de deux enfants et j'étais extrêmement
frustrée de voir que lorsque je déposais
mon enfant je n'avais pas accès à ce qui
pouvait faire
Isabelle Matuidi qui est la femme de
Blaise Matuidi de la Juventus
avec la France ancien joueur du PSG et
de la Juventus Turin il réagit suite à
cette inauguration et au parcours dans
l'entrepreneuriat de sa femme on
l'écoute c'est important d'être au côté
de ma femme je suis fier d'elle de ce
que de ce qu'elle est en train
d'accomplir on a quatre enfants donc on
sait ce que c'est l'éveil des enfants et
honnêtement voilà de voir que elle
grandit elle a cet esprit
entrepreneur qui qui prend le dessus
aujourd'hui et pour moi c'est une fierté
merci Isabelle et Blaise Matuidi des
propos collectés par Mathilde Francou
Blaise matuy forcément j'imagine qu'en
tant qu'amoureux de sport amoureux de
fou nous en gardez un très bon souvenir
ah oui ben champion Champion du Monde
2018 ça on pourra pas lui enlever et il
nous a fait rêver Blaise Matuidi qui a
stoppé sa car il y a très peu de temps
il a du côté de Miami il a joué l'Inter
de de Miami et il a stoppé il y a
quelques mois donc tout fraîchement
retraité champion du monde et qui a joué
à Poissy aussi
le l'avantage merci Michael pour toutes
ces précisions on se retrouve bien sûr
dès lundi prochain pour de nouvelles
actualités sportives c'est bientôt la
fin de ce 7 8 mais avant on va jeter un
dernier coup d'oeil à la météo de demain
et le vent qui va souffler assez fort
demain matin dans les Yvelines avec des
rafales annoncé à 50 km/h quelques
éclaircies prévus sur l'ensemble du
territoire pour les températures il fera
8 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et Versailles
7 degrés à Houdan et
à Houdan et Rambouillet l'après-midi de
la pluie pourrait tomber sur le
département côté température 9 degrés
sur le secteur Nord et Centre du
département 8 degrés à Rambouillet ce
mardi à 14 mars c'est la sainte Mathilde
voilà c'est la fin de ce 7 8 merci de
votre fidélité on se retrouve bien sûr
dès demain pour une nouvelle édition
belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]